اديسون ارتس 2 سمنتو الشهير باسم بيليه
ولد في 23 من اكتوبر سنه
1940 بالبرازيل يعتبر احد اعظم اللاعبين
في كل العصور باعتراف الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم الذي وصفه بالافضل على الاطلاق وكان
من بين اكثر الشخصيات الرياضيه نجاحا
وشعبيه في القرن العشرين الاسطوره بيليه
افضل من داعب كره القدم على وجه الارض حسب
كثيرين
اختارته اللجنه الاولمبيه الدوليه رياضيه
القرن عام 99 وتم ادراجه في قائمه التايمز
لاهم 100 شخصيه اختيار من قبل الاتحاد
الدولي لتاريخ واحصاء كره القدم افضل لاعب
في العالم لكل الاوقات
انجازاته بيليه تؤكدها الحصيله الرقميه من
الاهداف التي وصلت الى
1179 هدفا في 13
و63 مباراه لعبها بما في ذلك المباريات
الوديه وكلها مدونه ضمن كتاب غينيس
للارقام القياسيه وسامت في تتويجه بجائزه
لاعب القرن الماضي من الفيفا الى جانب
الارجنتيني مارادونا عاش بيليه طفوله
فقيره في باورو بولايه ساو باولو حصل على
اموال اضافيه من خلال العمل في المقاهي
كنادر قبل ان يشق طريقه كي يصبح احد افضل
واشهر من مارسوا كره القدم عبر التاريخ
بدات اللعب مع سانتوس في سن الخامسه عشر
والمنتخب البرازيلي في سن السادسه عشر
وخلال مسيرته الدوليه فاز بثلاثه نهائيات
لكاس العالم وهو اللاعب الوحيد الذي فعل
ذلك هو اصغر متوج بكاس العالم ايضا وعمره
لم يتجاوز السابعه عشرته هو الهداف
التاريخي للبرازيلي الى جانبي نيمار 77
هدفا وعلى مستوى النادي هو الهداف
التاريخي وايضا لسانتوس ب
643 هدفا باليه وبعد اعتزاله في العام 77
من القرن الماضي حصل على العديد من
الجوائز الفرديه والجماعيه لادائه في هذا
المجال وانجازاته القياسيه وارثه في عالم
الرياضه